[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily all I
know is a piece of my heart was not just
cut out but it was ripped out of my damn
chest jurors here from victims families
in the Parkland school shooter penalty
phase trial plus basketball player
Brittany Greiner could soon face
sentencing in a Russian drug trial as
negotiations of a prisoner trade
received backlash and Shakira's alleged
tax fraud could the singer Face Time
behind bars but first Pilates are
worthless
at this stage any apology would not be
sincere and it's come too late the
plaintiff suing Infowars host Alex Jones
take the stand in the Sandy Hook Civil
Trial in Texas law and crime daily
covering court cases from coastic coast
[Music]
Nancy Weber in for Brian buckmeyer the
parents of a six-year-old boy killed at
Sandy Hook Elementary School tell a
Texas jury how broadcaster Alex Jones's
theories about the shooting impacted
them and how they're still feeling the
effects a decade later in December 2012
a gunman killed 20 first grade students
and six staff members at the Connecticut
school after the incident Jones told his
Infowars audience it was all a quote
hoax and staged with actors in order to
push gun control Jones later said he
believed the shooting did happen but
claims he had a right to say it didn't
the families of several victims sued the
political conspiracy theorist over the
comments including Neil hesslin and
Scarlett Lewis a couple who lost their
son Jesse that fateful day courts in
both Texas and Connecticut found Jones
liable for defamation entering default
judgments against him saying he ignored
several court orders and failed to
respond to Discovery demands juries will
now determine what he will pay in
Damages before the plaintiff rested on
Tuesday heslin told jurors to this day
he care carries a photo of Jesse with
him saying even though he was only six
years old his son died a hero and that
any apology from Jones at this point
would be worthless
he died two feet from his teacher the
gunman's gun Jam
point at one point
she knew that
at that moment
because she yelled first classmates to
run
addictive
live today because of his actions 11
survived
told her in the bathroom
because she died
Mr Hessel is holding Alex Jones
accountable for what he's done
necessary in your mind to move on with
your life
it is
this trial is the only way I can restore
my credibility gravitation
destroyed and damaged by
constant attacks and
cuddling at a conspiracy and hopes Alex
Jones's policies or apologies are
worthless
at this stage
and Tuesday afternoon Jesse's mother
Scarlett took the stand telling jurors
how her life is still impacted a decade
after the shooting
we're briefly that you own a gun at your
house
is that is that because of the safety
fears that you have
yes
if you'd like explain a little further
and responsible for the safety of both
of my boys
and
I was not able to keep one of them safe
and so I am going to keep
my surviving Sun save
and you can tell
I could tell by
the info or the two people that
testified from Infowars as well as Alex
Jones that they don't care
that's also deeply unsettling
all right let's break this down joining
us today is co-host Terry Austin and
legal analyst Dr Tracy Pearsons great to
see you both Dr Pearson I'll start with
you you know Tuesday's testimony from
Jesse Lewis's clearance was clearly
emotional but the question is is it more
powerful is it different than expert
testimony
it is jurors don't consider information
in a vacuum so what they're hearing
information about and who is providing
it to them is what matters and nothing
uh sells uh loss and impact like human
vulnerability and that's what we're
seeing here with these parents Terry as
we're watching this Texas trial and as
it's ongoing jury selection began on
Tuesday in a separate Alex Jones
defamation case out of Connecticut so is
there any way that could complement you
know complicate this in any way it could
be a logistical issue
it is a logistical nightmare there are
two trials in Texas and one in
Connecticut in connection with the Sandy
Hook shooting and what Alex Jones said
about those shootings saying that it was
a hoax one trial has been delayed the
Connecticut trial because he filed for
bankruptcy but the judge said she wanted
that to move forward now he's also filed
to remove it to the bankruptcy court so
she has to at least determine whether or
not it's going to be moved so it is
halted for now but this Texas case is
moving forward the Witnesses are on the
stand as you can see there and I think
we'll get a decision relatively quickly
because it is moving relatively quickly
frankly I think that Jones is delaying
because he wants to make sure that all
of these cases don't go forward he's
already been found liable as we know and
it's just a question of Damages at this
point you know what could complicate it
Jones on the stand which is what we are
planning to talk about tomorrow and I
will tell you him testifying him saying
something is going to be definitely
something to watch all right we move
over now to Georgia where body cam
footage was released showing an incident
surrounding a mother of two falling out
of the back seat of a police car which
led to her death last month Brianna
Greer was experiencing a mental health
episode when her mother called police
for help her family says that they've
had to call law enforcement several
times in the past but an ambulance would
come in addition to the police this time
only the police came and the family's
Attorney Ben Crum says that they entered
the home handcuffed Greer and placed her
in the back seat of a patrol car for
allegedly resisting arrest moments after
the patrol car pulls away Greer falls
out of the passenger side back seat and
officials later determined that the door
was open new video shows the moments
after the fall
foreign
died days later in the hospital and now
her family is demanding answers after
receiving conflicting explanations still
ahead on Law and crime daily WNBA player
Brittany Greiner back in Russian court
on a cannabis charge amid U.S efforts to
secure her release but first Shakira in
some legal hot water as she decides to
take accusations of alleged tax fraud to
trial in Spain
[Music]
welcome back everybody Shakira could
face up to eight years behind bars as
Spanish authorities accuse the singer of
tax fraud a ruling dating back to July
2021 found that Shakira could stand
trial for alleged tax evasion for 2012
2013 and 2014. authorities in Spain say
the singer lived there for more than 200
days in each of those years making her
liable to pay taxes there now while
Shakira's team argued her main residence
was in the Bahamas a Barcelona judge
accused the singer and her financial
advisor of using offshore accounts to
hide our income sources Shakira's public
relations team now says the singer did
not reach an agreement with Spanish
prosecutors and will head to trial to
maintain her innocence a statement reads
in part quote Shakira and her team
consider that this case constitutes a
total violation of her rights since she
has always shown impeccable Behavior as
a person and taxpayer all right let's
break this down Terry I'll start with
you Shakira's team says they're you know
they're confident that they can prove
the singer's innocence but what could a
defense look like here I've always
thought these cases were straightforward
well you know the team is claiming that
the authorities are really just chasing
after her and that oftentimes they do
this to people and they often lose and
the authorities are claiming that she
hasn't paid her taxes from 212 2012 to
2014 and they're saying Chio is about 14
million dollars but the defense is look
she lives in the Bahamas where you don't
have to pay income taxes she's only in
Spain sporadically and they are
rejecting any deals because their claim
is look she's completely and totally
innocent she's always cooperated she's
always paid her taxes and furthermore
she has been taking the advice of
pricewaterhouse and so it is nothing
that she's trying to evade she's
basically just following the advice and
following the law and she's being
falsely accused frankly of trying to
evade taxes so I think we're going to
see a complete trial and I think she's
going to take this all the way because
their defense is I'm innocent
great defense on paper but Dr Pearson
let's say it doesn't work what's the
likelihood she's actually going to spend
eight years in prison for this
well Spain has become very aggressive
over the years with tax prosecution uh
and it wasn't originally but with
Andorra a small little country nearby
becoming a tax Haven they have pursued
folks that have have a lot of tax uh to
pay and and Shakira has a lot of tax
that she she apparently should be paying
um we're looking at prosecutors are
asking for eight years two months which
is the max right and we're thinking
probably at the very least time served
if her no criminal record is considered
and the judge takes the mercy on her all
right this is not the kind of Spotlight
she wanted to be in I'll tell you that
much we'll continue to follow the
Shakira case but let's actually move
over now to New Jersey a hit and run
caught on camera finds a city leader in
hot water long crime networks Sierra
Gillespie has the story
a hit and run caught on camera shows a
New Jersey city councilwoman Lee the
scene of a crash it happened at about
eight o'clock in the morning on July
19th the Jersey City closed circuit TV
cameras caught the crash on video
showing a Nissan Rogue slam into a biker
and then drive off video shows the biker
get hit and flip over twice in the air
all as their shoes fly off into the
street the bike is then thrown over to a
nearby curb seconds later the biker
slowly gets up and a crowd begins to
appear a witness then collects the
Biker's shoes as the biker rests on the
sidewalk the Jersey City mayor's office
now says the person behind the wheel was
councilwoman Amy dege the biker was
identified as 29 year old Andrew black
who told news outlets he's experiencing
shoulder hip and ankle pain since the
crash black admits degrees had a green
light and that he pedaled through a red
light but says that doesn't excuse her
from driving off Jersey City residents
have now taken to social media calling
for degiz's immediate resignation
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie
great report
there coming up on Long Prime daily the
state's case begins to wind down in the
Parkland school shooting penalty phase
trial as Victim Impact statements are
presented in court plus Brittany
greiner's trial resumes in Russia over
drug possession charges here when the
trial is expected to end that's coming
up
foreign
welcome back everybody officials in
Russia say the Brittany Greiner trial
could wrap up soon as the WNBA star
appears in court once again Tuesday Mark
Reiner's first time back in court since
the Biden Administration proposed a
trade now the deal would allow Greiner
back into the United States in exchange
for Russian arms dealer Victor bout the
Basketball Star in Olympian has been
detained in Russia since February when
she was arrested for carrying cannabis
oil with Moscow airport Greiner was
charged with attempting to smuggle
illegal narcotics into Russia she
pleaded guilty to the charges but
testified that she did not intentionally
bring an illegal substance into the
country on Tuesday a Russian expert
testified on griner's behalf saying an
analysis of the confiscated Vape
cartridges did not meet Russian legal
requirements originally expected to last
for months greiner's attorney now says
closing arguments are set to be
presented on Thursday let's make sense
of this Dr Tracy I'm going to start with
you you know we still have kind of
limited information Nation about this
potential Dre the trade of Griner for
this Russian arms dealer but how do you
think that this is going to play out
what could you expect from this proposal
well the proposal
was convicted he was arrested in 2018
convicted in 2020 of uh Espionage and he
is American by naturalization so the
idea would be to to gather him and to
gather Brittany Greiner and bring them
home in exchange for this arms dealer
now this arms dealer was convicted of
conspiracy to kill Americans and to
deliver anti-aircraft missiles so the
Russians want him back
Terry the conviction rate for criminal
cases in Russia is reportedly very high
doesn't mean that Greiner would
necessarily lose but the question is how
is her defense team doing so far at this
point given all the circumstances
well you know what Jesse you are
absolutely right it is a high conviction
rate reportedly that we've heard in
Russia for criminal cases and this is a
criminal case so it seems like a
foregone conclusion and I do think that
that is why she pleaded guilty but the
defense has done a great job so far
first of all she was on that stand she
testified that as you said she
accidentally packed this substance and
it wasn't intentional she knew what the
law was in Russia and it was inadvertent
we also saw on this stand a physician
who testified that she uses this for
medical reasons that she has pain and
it's from her basketball playing her
knees are really in pain and so she has
to use this and many apparently do use
this for these types of athletic
injuries and we also saw character
Witnesses who testified that she's a
supportive player that she's a great
teammate and we saw the director of that
basketball team get on the stand and he
said the same thing that she's a very
supportive player all right seems like
the defense is doing all they can given
the circumstances we'll follow those
closing arguments as well when we come
back we head to Florida for the Parkland
school shooter penalty phase trial
you're going to hear the emotional
Victim Impact statements from parents
whose children were killed in the
shooting
[Music]
welcome back everybody emotional Victim
Impact statements are presented in the
Parkland school shooter penalty phase
trial 17 people were killed and 17 more
injured when a gunman opened fire at
Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School in
February 2018. last year the gunman
pleaded guilty to all charges and is now
up to Florida Florida jurors to decide
whether he receives life in prison or
the death penalty as the penalty phase
trial entered week three family members
of victims gave impassioned Victim
Impact statements
my first born daughter my shining star
Daddy's girl was taken from me
I get to watch my friends my neighbors
colleagues spending time enjoying their
daughters enjoying all the normal
Milestones taking in the joys and I can
only watch videos or go to the cemetery
see my daughter
it was four years ago to everyone but to
me it was yesterday
Alyssa will always be 14.
while the world gets to move on with
their lives we don't have that luxury
missing our door that every single day
no parent is supposed to have this grief
without our daughter Alyssa
her lives have been changed
forever
we have an empty bedroom in our house
foreign
chair at our dining table
Alex
will never have a brother to talk or
hang out with
they will never again go for a dry
blasting very loud music
we did not get to see Nick graduate from
high school or college
we will not get to see him getting
married
we will always hesitate before answering
the question how many kids do you have
there are no words to express how much
we all miss snake
the world is missing out not having
making it
Dr Pearson those Victim Impact
statements are just heartbreaking
they're so difficult to listen to and
you also hear the parents rightfully
angry how do you think that that anger
is going to affect the jury
well jurors are fact-finders and even
though we are hearing a different kind
of evidence and we're seeing a
non-adversarial process to this point uh
they are fact binders and are going to
apply those facts hopefully objectively
to the law at hand however we can't
close out the possibility that these
jurors are going to be impacted by just
the the circumstances and the terrible
nature of these children's deaths you
know Terry the judge told the jury that
they were going to hear these Victim
Impact statements but she also cautioned
and said these statements are not going
to count as mitigating factors in your
analysis when you weigh the aggravating
and mitigating factors to determine life
in prison or the death penalty so I
guess the question is from a legal point
of view what is the purpose of these
statements well that is very true she
specifically said that these should not
be mitigating or aggregating factors in
your consideration because legally they
have already outlined what the
aggravating factors are here and those
are the fact that you know this was a
heinous crime it was cold and calculated
it was a capital felony he had previous
convictions of capital felony and so
those are the specific by law
aggravating factors but the perfect the
impact statements is really for each of
the families to show the unique impact
that the loss has on their family so
they go through they give examples of
how those victims have impacted their
lives and how their lives are different
now and it really does give the family
some closure the other purpose is that
it does allow the defendant to hear what
he has done as far as how he's affected
those families so it serves a unique
purpose even though technically it's not
supposed to be in aggravating factors
you know in the back of the minds of
those juries they're going to be
thinking about that for a fact yeah and
who knows what the defendant is thinking
when he listens to this Dr Pearson Terry
thank you so much and everyone out there
thanks for joining us here on Long crime
daily we're going to see you next time
as we discuss Justice in America
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]